not a lie that was rough and I'm
speechless 12 years of slave yes special
thank you to all of you who actually
understand that when the movie gets a
limited release it may be playing in
about two theaters within a 50 mile
radius of my house both of those
theaters being 30 miles away
thank you for exercising understanding
withholding the Jeremy Jones's or racist
comments I appreciate that
now that I've seen 12 years of slave
let's review it so 12 years of slave is
the disturbingly true story about an
african-american guy in slave America
times who lives in New York he's a free
man no one owns him but if a couple of
douche bags sell him into slavery while
he's passed out drunk in the night I
guess now he's a slave and that's
exactly what happens
I always knew him as the assassin and
serenity and I knew this guy was a good
actor but holy quote me on this if
and when this movie gets nominated for
Best Picture he should and will get
nominated for Best Actor because he is
the movie it's his movie but I'm getting
ahead of myself so in the course of this
movie it's his life for the next 12
years of him being a slave and it's
disturbingly real I don't know about you
but when I was in high school we always
learned about slavery yeah and they
always showed you some boring movie that
never really captured the brutality of
it all the injustice of buying selling
and trading people like their Pokemon
cards it's just this movie
completely accurately captures it you
watch it and it's just it's so
unapologetically brutal and in-your-face
it's one of those movies that it can't
sugarcoat it and do the situation
justice today it's hard to grasp the
concept that someone could just beat and
murder somebody because they are their
property you don't see that on a regular
basis so when the movies like now here
it is in all of its gory fashion just
sit there like oh oh my god I
like a movie that puts a situation like
this in your face it's really effective
seeing a guy who was free become a slave
you know he's gonna fight it for the
first while and at a point in the movie
he just he will give in to his situation
he's like I am a slave forever you can
see the moment the absolute moment where
it hits him in the eyes raised like this
is my life now I'm never getting out of
here everyone in the movie did a great
job you can tell there were actors where
you're like oh that should be a big part
like Brad Pitt's in the movie briefly
but you can tell he was like yeah I want
to be a part of this movie Benedict
Cumberbatch
in the movie and it's interesting
because he does become the slave
property of a few different people
Cumberbatch is one of them and I even
said this works like well as slave
owners go that person was actually not
bad and when someone says that in the
movie the other person in the
conversation is like as far as slave
owners go he's a slave owner and that is
the thing at two sides culturally
speaking a lot of people owned slaves
I'm sure if they live today and they
looked back they'd be like yeah if I
could do it over I would do it over not
owned slaves I think that is the mental
situation of the people other characters
in this movie are just complete pieces
of like Michael Fassbender's
character let it be clear everyone in
this movie that I can think of did a
great job in the movie everyone killed
it there's going to be a few nominations
for this movie Michael Fassbender is
going to be one of them this guy is an
he is a douchebag he just loves
to cause pain he gives a couple of
monologues where you were just baffled
you're like you just see them as
property Michael Fassbender in this
movie is like Calvin Candie from Django
Unchained but real that's right this is
not Django Unchained you don't kick back
and go oh my god just does a good job in
this movie can sell DiCaprio's having
fun which is great for Django Unchained
I'm just saying you walk out of this
movie going I can't sleep if I can
describe 12 years of slave by mixing
movies you know I like doing that
comparing to movies and making them one
it's like Schindler's List meets
Shawshank Redemption if I'm gonna look
you in the eyes and say this movie is an
easy watch that would be a bold-faced
lie it's not easy to watch but
I will look you in the eyes and say it
is absolutely worth watching one of the
best movies of the year hands down
movies are like weapons in Assassin's
Creed you got the sword and it can hit
over and over and over and over again
you can watch it over and over and over
and it does its job just fine other
things I like that that knife that comes
out of a Chios wrists all it needs is to
hit once in the right spot and down you
go that's 12 years of slave because 12
years a slave is awesome tacular
it's okay if you cry in this movie I did
right so 12 years a slave have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more